non je vais faire des couteaux parce
qu'il répond pas mais c'est normal je
pense comme il connaît pas mon numéro il
doit se dire ok c'est une image qui me
harcèle donc je fais un texto comme ça
on est libéré après je vois là je vais
mettre un truc simple genre salut un
sens c'est florence foresti ce qui ne
connaît pas donc je vais quand même
non j'ai précisé voilà on est on est aux
césars compte à temps voilà michael
parfait enfin pas d'accord je vais quand
même être un emoticon derrière un smiley
ça va calmer parce que sinon ça fait
honte à temps c'est un peu je mette un
truc qui calme je m ah oui je sais je
met mon préféré gens mais tu es tu là
s'il fait tout avaler celui-là chéri
j'ai cassé la porsche c'est là un ils
veulent te regarde je t'es trompé
oui tout tout tout félix n'est pas ton
fils eu ça passe
j'hésite avec aa ou alors je vois tu là
non je ne connais pas assez faut être
intime celui-là être très très bien lui
et d'ailleurs je conseille d'ailleurs à
tous les agents artistiques qui sont
dans la salle de l'utiliser quand ils
vont devoir prévenir leurs artistes qui
l'ont pas eu
1 tu n'as pas eu ça va mais tu restes le
meilleur